[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classics the third day of
the 2017 spring chess classic saw
grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang emerge atop
the leaderboard in Group A will be
joined by Jeffrey Zhang today to talk
about his victory and also a Group C
competitor for the first time eally
initiative the 2017 spring chess classic
features a combined prize fund of more
than 50 grand win the top prize in Group
A that will get you $6,000 $4,000 is the
prize for Group B and the top prize for
Group C is $5,000 that's because Group C
is actually stronger than Group B group
a to my left right here 16 year-old
Jeffrey Zhang grandmaster who is the
world Junior Chess Champion and right
now he's sitting atop of the group
Jeffrey congratulations today in your
victory is white over year view cache
conscious really I'd like you to go over
the game for us and show us some of the
more memorable points he took Queen
takes rook c8 I was thinking maybe here
he could try this new queen of six to
attack on b2 and I was playing to Castle
he takes rook ad 140 enter and they just
quit a3 and the problem is she has this
week D pawn and probably out win this
pawn but we'll get some four versus
three ending and yes I joined gymnast
but in the game he opted for rook c8 and
after castles I think now it was already
very difficult to save one of these
funds because I mean if if he protects
like Queen d7 I think I can just take on
this one
and it's going to be a clip on up so in
the game you tried this idea night
before takes
and a-five and his idea was try to move
his bishop so and hope that he has these
open files in selectivity and hope it's
enough for the pawn but in the end I
don't think it's enough because after 93
I didn't see a better way for him then
it should be six and then I take
everything here maybe his best chance
was Bishop takes a two and I was going
to play Knight to six takes rook into
and try to hold this position probably
something like g6 and I'm up a pond but
again it's Fleck still have some joint
changes because in the game he basically
allowed me to keep both palms and not
just up to palms and it's not clear
whether uh whether or not he can really
generate some play against my f2 pawn
because my knight is dominating his rook
so his real can't really get into the
game so I thought it was just two palms
up and he tried to put his Bishop on a4
but I don't think it led to much so I
played Bishop b4 with threatening on
Knight f3 so she had to move this night
and then here it was a bit bizarre
moment we repeated and I think he should
have just gone back and then I would
probably have to go with the other rook
rook a to and something like maybe look
c5 here or if CC and I still have to
show some technique but in the game she
played this way ripped b6 which just
gave me some at least two exercises
I play rook c1 and I threatened to
invade this tradition and eventually it
was quite simple so here unfortunately
King d8 doesn't work for him because I
take and 96 looks like a fork cut I
believed rook a4 holds everything and g5
rook at six
there's a pin here so he can't take
anything and then in the game he tried
to play it like this but I found a way
to play I mean take his phone and then
Joker 5 was important and the idea is
not a few tries take on e3 it's just an
8-inch f7 in your cage 5 and meanwhile I
threaten rubgy 5c pieces if he tries
some moves like Knight f6 it's also just
made with g5 and 9 o'clock so I think he
found the only way to prevent mate which
is h6 stopping rip g5 and now the ideas
of Fishbach 7 he goes cage 7 and there's
no me but now I have this idea Bishop b4
which threatens some discoveries and
really there's no way out cuz only
square available is h7 but that doesn't
do anything so the game finished 933 and
rook takes d5 and he resigned in view of
king at 7:56 if we're picked before I
just gave a check and I'm up in
exchanging three pawns so he played I
mean if she has to try to take on x1 but
here I can even keep my extra piece but
with Bishop g6 and king of fate not of 5
and here he can't defend against my 2/3
would be a mate and 10 picks apart so
you just resign duster with 60
well very cool Jeffrey congratulations
on the victory once again what are your
thoughts so far any general thoughts on
the format of the Spring Classics yeah I
think it's a very nice event especially
with this extra group I think some
spectators get a lot of action so when
you have this many game things down to
become insane game ship I think really
nice for matches do you see yourself
winning the field
I think it's early to say they're all
these guys are quite strong so it's
quite an open event but yeah that's my
go to me well it was great having you
Jeffrey thank you very much the world
junior champion maybe one of the
favorites to win group a let's take a
look at the standings after three rounds
like Jeffrey said it's still early and
even though he's in the lead it's only
by a half a point and look at the log
jam after Jeffrey Jean eight players
tied at one and a half tomorrow Zhang
has the black pieces against Grandmaster
yaro zero book one of the competitors in
this year's US Championship as we
glanced at group b christian korilla and
a wonder Lang won their games today to
stay at the top of the leaderboard
tomorrow's game of the day will
undoubtedly be a wonder liang with the
black pieces taking on brazilian
grandmaster alexander fears and now for
the first time we come to Group C the
oddball group the sixth player double
round-robin I'm sitting here with Ilya
newzik the Ukrainian Grandmaster and he
has just defeated andrey zhuk open with
the black pieces congratulations on your
victory thank you very much
you said you were surprised out of the
opening oh yeah correct on great choice
brother red line in the CARICOM he
played the 92 on a forest move I'm not
really sure what that line is cold but
it's pretty rare hi I didn't see it that
often and I I had to pretty much prefer
from a scratch honestly because not
going to lie I didn't know that fine but
after the games he told me that
thing I've liked everything I've done
was the main line so I guess I figured
it out if I saw this move Bishop g5 I
would have given myself an excellent
explanation mark for the night c2 but
unfortunately I didn't see Bishop g5 and
that's what my opponent was very afraid
of he said that after Bishop g5 all of a
sudden this idea the Bishop III check
and Bishop takes d4 white cannot really
protect themselves from it
what's a king h1 Bishop III and let's
say white takes an a6
I can just click win d5 and I would take
on before our next move so it it really
surprises me because I didn't see this
over the board but my opponent told me
that it's just very bad for white so I
guess I mean he spent a lot of time here
after a point 92 so I guess he he kept
calculated everything very well so I'm
gonna not going to double check it and
yeah but in fact after 1 to a4 I was
planning to point at e3 which is very
bad for me and when I'd be one Queen
takes d1 I would save my I would save
the fees because now I can just take on
c5 but instead I would I would have
watched the a6 pawn and my position
would still be very bad
unlike the position after Bishop to g5
so during the game I did not I didn't I
can't really say I played well this game
I actually thought it's not over yet but
I mean my phone was just so afraid of of
this Bishop g5 after okay for that he
decided to go for a sec for peace
sacrifices and I definitely six which
appear to be incorrect I'll show you the
rest of the game but my opponent was
pretty quickly so now we need 7 when I
take c1 rook takes a 1 now the point is
that if I don't do anything this this
whole oh it's all these central pawns
I'm going to get moving
opening up the C Street Bishop and I
might have some problems with my King or
sudden so now I have to I have to
quickly do something about it so I
decided to
give my exchange back and go to this
position instead so here I'm not really
sure what what map on could do
differently but I'm not sure about the
movie was made with the Moose he was
making probably it was because of the
time pressure although I didn't really
see the the better alternative for him
so here the the alternative to what he
did he put a ch3 which is probably
moving in a spot after after quintic c4
but here I thought that maybe 21 right
away would have prolonged the game a
little bit further because now if I just
take on e4
what would would take on a6
actually I taken only forth no because
it is now I I'm not going to I'll
probably still win a pawn
eventually but I can do it easier by
taking on e5 first twin takes a 6 Queen
takes e4 so here I mean I'm a pawn and
white rook on g1 is extremely passive so
I think this might still be winning for
me I'll probably just get the C pawn
moving geta to see to an eventual Queen
that's what I was thinking my opponent
would do but he didn't hit with h3
instead here I took on e4 and here
probably because of time pressure map
and actually I'm not really even sure if
it was a time pressure he put in f3
which one dress the second pawn after
rook e1 check rook takes Queen takes
King h2 Quint xe5 but I'm not really
sure if if there was something better he
could do here once again the root G one
out here yeah now g1 whose's immediately
because the rook III so nice one Queen
a6 and rook takes h3 checkmate so
another move here would be 23 which also
goes as soon as particles of the same
rope III go into h2 mmm okey one check
and I'll actually get trade Queen
and the opponent game is winning for me
because I'm a pawn and my king is way
closer to this pawn so I will eventually
take the e5 phone as well
so here yeah my one plate when s Raiders
this version is really it's probably
lost already so he just decided to give
it a try and try to save this Queen
endgame unfortunately have I just have
way too many points to play with so I
when she was able to finish the game now
just to show you the rest of it here the
only challenge in this position is that
I have to watch out for perpetual checks
and not to lose my my NC pawns at the
same time but I think I've found a way
to to make work so now clean this room
I'm not actually losing my c6 bonus he
checks but the thing is here my opponent
promotes an a3 followed by a2 and a1
queen so that was my game not I mean I
can't really say that I've played it
well but yeah at the end everything
works out I guess I just got a little
bit lucky but yeah that's me well and
that's you and that's you wearing a
Webster University jacket I'm telling
you these guys at Webster you can always
tell a Webster gorlok because they're
always walking around with a stylish
jacket what's going on next with Susan
builders Goldilocks I'm not really sure
I don't think we have anything planned
but I mean obviously one of the most
important events for Webster Webster
chefs seen as an American
intercollegiate tournament and as well
as Final Four but that will be in
like almost half a year so live we're
still preparing very hard for that event
but I mean we've got a lot of time to
work with so we'll try our best to get
or settle ourselves ready for those
events and do our best and our players
also play individually we play a lot of
tournaments and I'm personally plan to
playing a lot of tournaments in summer
such as world opening US Open etc
they'll be going around the air spring
and hopefully I can improve my quality
of chairs so that they can I can see
moves as the 55 in future it's very easy
move but yeah I didn't see it over the
board so I really have to work on that
well congratulations on your point today
Ilya really Grand Master iliyan is Nick
let's take a look now at standing for
Group C after their fourth round in the
double round-robin
Hylian is Nick was the only player to
win today the other two games were draws
on Friday May 19th we'll see if a player
can break away from the pack as mission
it takes on roof Bingley and sibian
takes on board to stay with us through
Wednesday May 24th as every round begins
at 1:00 p.m. with the exception of the
final day see the move by move live as
it happens at just 24 calm and us chess
champs calm